saplings in full bloom
some of the pods are already nearly ripe
orlando osmano is expecting a rich cocoa
harvest this year
this cocoa grows very fast it's not like
what we used to plant
it would take the old cocoa seeds four
years to bear fruit
but with these it's only two years to
win their quantum i
the quantum power that's really fast for
us
it means we can all enjoy it and make
money earlier
it wasn't always like this two years ago
the trees were hit by a disease called
swollen shoot virus
which left harvests ruined
here's how orlando described the
situation back then
this is a part that could have matured
but didn't because of the disease
it's no good for harvest it's spoiled
radical action was needed orlando osmano
followed the advice of experts
and felled his trees it wasn't an easy
decision
initially i wasn't sure about what they
told us but i thought about it and cut
down one and a half acres out of 14.
it's been two years now and i'm very
happy two years
but sick trees weren't his only problem
he
also had to look on while part of his
land was cleared to make way for a path
all of this is part of the farm i
planted plantain cocoa and everything
here just like in the other parts
but the timber contractors cleared it
and didn't give me anything
so i'm white
to deal with the problem of illegal
felling locals across the district are
being trained up to work as forest
monitors
they use an app to report their findings
it only takes a couple of taps
we are not just identifying illegalities
and saying that it is
illegal but we identify then we make a
report on it then we take action
together with the first commission
to address the problem
farmers in the bia district know how
important their trees are for the
climate
and keep the soil healthy felling trees
leads to drier conditions
that in turn leaves the trees more
vulnerable to pests
like these ants
orlando osmano is dealing with an
infestation
but he has a trick
if i block it this way no air gets to
the ant and so they die
inside
simple and effective
but just as things were starting to look
up for him and his family
the coronavirus struck raising fears
about how the disease will
impact his business
it's become a problem covert has really
don't come you have no choice but to
live with that worry we're
farmers like orlando often have trouble
accessing loans
because their holdings are too small to
use as collateral
now a local savings initiative has been
established to help out and assist
farmers
in weathering the pandemic orlando was
among those
who attended a training session on
financial management
we know that after the establishment of
the new renovated farms
it takes about three years or more
before the farm start fruiting
so smv under the scouts project taught
it twice
to link up with financial institutions
to see how they can support their
farmers during the post rehabilitation
phase before
the food starts the cocoa farms start
fruiting
orlando's hoping to use the loan to
expand and develop his plantation
he wants to be ready for what happens
after the pandemic
the improved prospects have even
prompted his son adama fusani
to consider quitting his job as a
teacher to give farming a go himself
now i can see a lot of improvements
actually my father is able to get food
to
feed the family and then some of the
food that he serves he's able to get
money from there some small income to
support the family
in one way the other and now i'm even
excited to go into
full farming a new generation and
a good harvest in sight for orlando
osmano
things are looking up
you